sala e rezistencës dëshmon per luftën dhe per pjeket e populit shqiptar pas dhejkes e Skenderbël.
Në këtë kol drejtimin u shhtarak e u dhoj qi leg du ka gjini,
i cili për njëmbëdhjet vjet me rall i bëri balsulmeve të uštrive Osmanë.
Renja e ka lasë së shkodrës me një 1479,
shënon edhe pushtimin e Shqipëris që shëqerohet me një serëvrasjesh dhe shkatërimesh në të gjith vendin.
Reddë 200.000 shqiptarë në pamëntsi të durojnë dhunën Osmanë
dë durojnë të emigrojnë në Italinë jughut arbëreshet të dukeruajtuara tje gjuhën,
kulturën dhe zakonët shqiptare në përmihet dokumentave të ekspozuara në vitrina të kësajsale,
dëshmojt se Skenderbël nuk shiste vetën një strategë u shhtarak,
por edhe një politika në diplomatikojës.
Ajin bante lidje diplomatike me mjaftë shtete të Evropës si Franca,
Germania, Austria, Spania, Italia, Grecia etje.
Janos hunjadi, herëj populit Hungares dhe Alfonso i Pesë,
mbreti na polit ishin du aleatët më tëngusht të Skenderbëjut në luftën anti-Osmanë.
Në këtë sal njiesh edhe me shumë vlerisime që i bëjn personalitete të kohës,
figurës se Skenderbël.
Për Skenderbëjut në janë shkruar mbi njëmi libre të gjinive të ndryshme,
në 70 të tre vendë të botës, në njëzet e pesë djuht të ndryshme.
Gjergj Arianiti, vjehri Skenderbëjut, udhejë qësi krengritive shqiptare të vite dhe një 1432-1435.
Brana Konti, komandanti kalasë se kurës në rethimin e sajtë parë, vitin 1450.
Mamita Kastrioti, motra e vogële herojtë, komandante kalasë se Petrelës prën Tiranas.
Tanush Topia, komandanti kalasë se kurës në rethimin e sajtë 223-1466-1467.
Lek Dukagjini, i cili pas dhekesë Skenderbëjut uvun e kurëtë ushtrisë shqiptare për njëmbëdhjet vjet meral.
Pal Kuka, diplomati Skenderbëjut.
Zahari Agropa, diplomati Skenderbëjut.
Gjergju Leshi, luftëtari që vrau Balaban pasën në rethimin e duqtë kurës, vitin 1416-1416.